well hello everyone it's now 9 o'clock
Pacific time this is Marc Newson from
Stanford University and I'd like to
welcome you to today's continuing series
of seminars in the big data to knowledge
programs guide to fundamentals of data
science today we have the honor of
having vodka can offers from McGill
University where she's director of the
Center for genetics and policy offer us
a talk on ethical issues related to data
science dr. Kapers is a professor and
holds a cake Canada Research Chair in
law and medicine she's a member of the
steering psilocybin experience or Cancer
Genome consortium and co-chair of the
regulatory and ethics working group of
the Global Alliance for genomics and
health her PhD is a comparative medical
law she has four honorary doctoral
degrees as an Officer of the Order of
Canada and Quebec and it is a real honor
for me to introduce her and for for us
to have an opportunity to hear about
this really important topic dr. Gerber's
thank you mark and hello everyone um
before I begin I'd like to thank my
Philips Research Associates who is here
with me at the Yale for all the work
that you put into helping me prepare for
this presentation I received
instructions to keep myself to 40
minutes to make sure you all have time
to ask questions so I will do that just
by way of preparation to the nail line
of my presentation I will look at the
current sort of self regulatory
approaches to the big data and ethical
issues that surround the use and
creation access and so on big data the
Commons approach which some of you are
we are aware of and others list of
future governance approaches and a new
proposed Human Rights approach to the
future of our big data and concludes
with some of
personal comments I'd like to also
stress that throughout my presentation
I'm concentrating on biomedical data
largely and I know by looking at some of
the past presentations that of course
the data crosses on all the fields of
social pure and applied on science by
way of introduction just so you don't
think that the preparing for this and
particularly looking at the privacy of
issues of big data in the biomedical
sphere I consider biomedical including
the medical part to be quite large in
other words to truly rule from research
to the best side you have to obviously
take into account geospatial data
surveillance data traffic socio-economic
data and so on before you can put the
data together to come to any kind of
predictive modeling now today I will be
concentrating on largely privacy and
data protection but most of you are
aware that since the human genome
project and its completion in 2003
there's been a question what do we do
with it now that we've found the sort of
the sequence human gene genome at the
level of the genome human genome how can
we unlock its health potential in a way
that allows data to be shared in a
secure way I should say on a global
level the thesis then or the hypothesis
is fact we will not get from the UN
genome to the population to precision
medicine to the patient
I let me really move from populations to
subpopulations in a sort of stratified
verification approach which again with
regroup data at our community levels or
sub population levels and then and only
then can we move to the patient taking
into account that are under the sort of
new emerging healthcare learning systems
approach patients themselves will soon
hopefully be part of with this
healthcare learning system moving from
use of their data and sample in medical
care into research and back to the
patient in order to be more precise so
it's sort of a feedback loop system that
I'm looking at a population two sub
population to patient stratification
system and finally the other contextual
background before I begin on the
self-regulatory is of the fact that
international scientific collaboration
is exponential this graph mean - nothing
scientists told me that most of
equations are incorrect but I liked the
way it was drawn so use it as a
background for this just to remind it is
that on sort of the individual Eureka
scientists working you know it alone in
the lab has still exists I hope so exist
but we're moving more towards a large
consortium crossing different
jurisdictions with different laws
different cultures and different values
and that in order to create the data to
use the data we have to keep that in
mind
and particularly different approaches to
privacy and security so what is actually
there to help to guide - to frame at
this point in time in 2017 well up to a
next year there are privacy guidelines
from the OECD since 1980 are next year
the general data protection regulation
from the EU will come into force and
I'll spit them bit more about that later
because for data to live here or to
enter Europe um we need to be cognizant
of what the impact of that data
protection regulation will be and the
effect cross-border privacy rules now
these are privacy rules for personal
data well all kinds on whether it's or
economic whether it's credit whether
it's demographic or or medical none of
these guidelines to date are
cific to the protection of health
information privacy and so you have to
take them as they emerge in the data
protection regulation which by the way
is going to be a regulation which in
Europe means it's law right before yet
directive now we're moving towards a
regulation which means that countries
will be less free to sort of interpret
it literally or conservatively in their
domestic legislation this will actually
be across-the-board regulation and the
mandatory so we'll have to see what this
means for data protection and data
sharing across borders moving from
Europe within Europe at overseas now one
of the first sort of self-regulatory
organizations to jump into the fray to
to bridge this gap between the
sequencing information genomic
information we have and the clinical
medical - - to bring the two worlds
together is the Global Alliance for
genomics and health which was created on
January 28 2013
now unbeknownst to most people this is
just a large international organization
of volunteers institutional volunteers
there are companies in there to use in
there with typical academics you're
under the patient foundations or
individuals are in there and so on if
simply an organization that wants to
prospectively if possible to ensure
interoperability harmonization
protection of participants and catalyze
if you wish in a positive sense data
sharing by creating tools framing
policies and so on to help to encourage
and to facilitate data sharing it does
not hold data it is not it's not in any
way bound by any organizational rules
it's not even incorporated so it's it's
actually at what I call an army of
volunteers who would like to move from
the mapping of the genome to an
international approach
to data sharing it did however I'll
develop a framework which I'll come back
to later on the manually rights approach
and immediately after the framework in
2014 did a series of policies of clauses
of templates a lexicon I can tell you
that took a lot of lawyers to play round
with words like the identification and
anonymization Sudan ization all tend to
mean different things in different
countries but I need to be understood
for data access and sharing privacy and
security policies a paper on being a
safe havens what are the attributes of a
center or an institute or project that
says you can deposit data here like DB
gap or ETA in Europe and would be
considered being a safe haven and you
don't have to spend hours and hours in
front of me the access committees are
ethics committees trying to explain an
accountability policy and an ethics
review recognition policy so I'm just
going to take a few minutes to give you
sort of the highlights of particular
highlights of what you might say is just
sort of a normal approach to these
issues
the first issue that everyone asked
about that was created in 2013 all the
way to the time of the framework and
then the consent policy was what do we
do with data where the word
international is omission what we're
sharing isn't Matt mentioned out of this
country is not there how do we not lose
on the contributions of citizens either
as patients or as research participants
by enabling and facilitating and in a
responsible way the sharing of legacy
data and this within borders and across
borders so that's a unique feature of
this consent policy
similarly for privacy and security
rather than taking the clinical trials
model where there is a high risk of harm
that drugs devices
Shire surgeries a placebo etc how do we
apply or not apply privacy and security
policy into what is largely data
intensive science so the Global Alliance
concentrates on data intensive science
it does not get in the way of the ith
clinical trials international accepted
approaches and so that's the question
when you are looking at harms and
benefits look at real harms not some
hypothetical one day somebody somewhere
might do something
perhaps real harms and real benefits and
take a proportionate approach in
evaluating a risks to privacy and data
integrity in the same mindset an
accountability policy whether it's
editors whether it's funders whether
it's researchers institutes universities
governments if you do have um data that
is just one element of this policy it's
more complicated that but if you do have
data that's consented for sharing why
aren't you sharing it and this believe
me on this sort of get a hoarding or
sitting on data actually on the mobile
lines consider to be an ethical issue
and so the countability policy speaks to
that and finally the last of policy is
the ethics review recognition policy
which is just a bit put two months ago
on the website of the golden lines the
ethics review ethics review recognition
our working group looked at the
different kinds of models I know that
the new common rule proposes a central
IRB in the NIH projects in the United
States under the common rule but we
looked at on reciprocity simply having
your sort of recognition that your
procedures are the same the way you
handle composition the way you look at
applications the way you act indicate
the way you respond and so on
characteristics are the attributes that
you use to evaluate so whether the lead
researchers in Germany or Japan we will
recognize our desire of the decision of
the other and so on a delegation model
or Federation model and so on I take on
the new ethics review recognition policy
gives you the kind of processes that
could be considered international to
allow or to to hopefully one day allow
international consortium to this
approach so that's the most those are
the most recent workings are in in the
field of big data and facilitating the
ethics foundations of the data that the
global lives has provided now even the
Human Genome Project has been
characterized as one of the first
projects that actually um took a Commons
approach and what do I mean by that
obviously the word says it all our
experts in and there are many professors
have written about this is holding
things in common putting things in
common under the notion of global public
goods and a common heritage and so on
life is important well and Plus on April
17 we already see them where you have
ready accessible access across countries
across borders and particularly a case
of rare conditions you can actually
solve or at least diagnose you might not
have a treatment or a cure on the case
of a patient in front of you and this is
thanks in part to this commons approach
now there are solutions with respect to
genomic databases that allow you to
connect with tonically which change
information in real time and very
quickly there are different kinds of
comments this is a very good article
that appears in science by a George
controllers and recommends all the
different types of comments that exist
now here at McGill always being a
working for a while under what's called
the can
for general collaboratory with Lincoln's
time trying to create a cloud commerce
for a cancer data obviously what was
behind this or spurred us to do this was
the international cancer 2 consortium
ICGC and we needed to pair on the
ethical and legal an aspirational I can
say that foundations for crossing all
cancers all countries and be able to
share data well the hopes are high on
that the cloud permits us to to do
computing in real time and and to look
for patterns and that of disease our
health but then allow us to formulate
hypotheses which is an interesting new
way of doing science rather than having
a process and going to the data go to
the data for your hypothesis and this
cancer genome laboratory has been
successful not only because it answered
many on technical and overcame many
technical barriers due to the sheer
volume of data but it also created by
can say this and a new community that
actually now has been transformed into
the genomic data Commons as it's known
since 2016 so this new kind of
intellectual data intensive Commons with
a particular approach to the genomic
always was actually why I call it self
regulatory it came from the researchers
it wasn't something that just appeared
on the market as a piece of software
they actually developed it because they
needed it and they thought that this was
the way to do data intensive science in
a humanistic sort of our way by data
sharing
so maximizers research benefits which
are funded at the same time offering
privacy protections now there many
worries as you know about sharing data
particularly in the car with you
NSA's mulden and
the rest and so moving forward we
realize that on with some European cases
is what lawsuits as well that the more
contextual data we bring in routing
let's say geospatial where you can see
of the socio-economic effects of lack of
universal health care lack of sidewalks
lack of public health strategies like a
fresh fruit or vegetables or water clean
water you can all very well this
together can have all different impacts
not just on the individual and imported
discrimination but on in different
context and with different human rights
that are affected and there's also the
issue of lack of control of legal
enforceability and what about used by
the street for surveillance yesterday I
was reading article about what do we do
about Facebook when you can see actual
murders being committed I mean you
actually have to think about how much
freedom um do we have at the same time
that we know that there is a need for
oversight and some monitoring to address
those risks and data privacy regulation
has not been drafted with big data or
the clouds in mind so how do we then
move towards the future in handling I
think most people would signed up for
such a webinar would be well aware of
the privacy security battle and social
risks of the data so turning men to
future governance and big data issues
the next slide looking at it from a
systems approach and interoperability
approach comes from the OECD and on the
OECD and convened a working group from a
thirty-five member countries to look at
health data governance um there was a
common understanding
that's your new data linkage linkage
between arm not only individuals of
individuals you move around but
individuals and other datasets to answer
specific questions what we all want hope
and are waiting for is linkage to
electronic health records and this not
just for an individual case or where you
see somewhere or particular for a
particular outcome but longer to do to
be able to follow individuals through
their records that's linked to other
records cancer registries rapidity
mortality of the kind of or even a
census records to be able to come to a
level of understanding of the impact of
the environment through environment writ
large on why some people are healthy we
always talk about disease and why others
are more susceptible or likely to become
ill even leaving genetic factors out of
it so this pathway then and all the data
trajectory has to look at the outcomes
and cost of having access using data or
not this means that one of the key
prerequisites in this healthcare ruling
system is to be able to follow patients
so not just your big research projects
here your 500,000 in the UK biobank
following people over time or Estonia
biobank
or Japan and so on the German wonderful
interoperable to some extent but
patients from birth to death so the
rationale then for this OECD
recommendations health data governance
which came up on January 17 2017 is that
um health data can advance health policy
objectives so if a particular country
has a particular health policy be a
child health maternal health aging and
health or they can actually have access
to the data that they need
project plan to promote in to prevent in
the system sense now there's no country
that is immune from using health data
and so what are the obstacles to using
help data effectively food is a deluge
of data if you can't decipher it or use
it and for this we need better on policy
frameworks to get more out of health
data so the OECD came up with a theory a
series of twelve to broad measures
accepted across the 35 countries and
believe me this is quite political it's
also cultural as I say things like
Public Interest Public Health are
interpreted differently in different
countries some narrowly some more
broadly so these are the large
categories and under each of these
categories there are actually procedural
guidance is provided for these are
measures that countries can then
incorporate into their into their
national domestic legislation or their
health care framework or ours system
however it is structured particular
interest to me was this one where it
actually came out and said that
government should support transporter
cooperation the processing of personal
health data and not just to make the
systems more cost effective or even
let's say sustainable from an economic
point of view but also for research for
statistics and other health related
purposes that serve the public interest
and obviously with certain safeguards so
they recommended to identify and remove
barriers to this because it's the
easiest thing to say well you know this
is a law in the country just hide and
run behind it and that's it typical
lawyer answer by the way and obviously
sometimes not even 100% true
you can also facilitate the
compatibility and interoperability of
health
government trailers look what works in
other countries that have a more
international sharing approach what
works what doesn't work and why and how
to remove those obstacles and what are
the mechanisms for that so this is where
I come to probably this is more of a
personal recommendation but it's
definitely the one that founded and
underscores all the work of me um global
alliance and that is let's switch things
around let's switch from a for the
bioethics framework anything largely
architected in the Helsinki Dec 11
Arabic code else in T declaration etc
one that's our C's research as necessary
but potentially harmful and almost
creates sort of a burden of proof on
researchers to overcome to show they're
not going to harm someone and with that
in mind of observe a positive approach
to science went around digging as
scholars are supposed to do and found
that in spite of my legal education I
had totally forgotten and I missed and
most people did probably your
international public saw one on one on
which included the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights of 1948 and in that
Universal Declaration there is an
article that talks about in the first
section the right to science and that
includes the right to share in
scientific advancement and its benefits
luckily for all those inventors
scientists artists and so on in the same
article there is a right to recognition
for authorship for being an inventor the
Chicago area coming up with something
that is recognized under intellectual
property copyright in and the like now
I'm not going to talk about 27 to
it's interesting to note that they do go
together so it's not because you think
everyone you know should share
everything and everybody should have
everything women and and that we do not
need to recognize the fruits of
intellectual and contribution so keeping
that in mind you say okay after
universal declaration looks nice paper
seen Eleanor Eleanor Roosevelt and then
the films on it and so on some but it
doesn't concern me well it does because
in 1966 these two rights in under
Article 27 were rendered legally binding
again something I missed by the
International Covenant on economic
social cultural rates 66 for a time
everything that done writing was
ratified I think was 1976 and in article
15 of that binding international
covenant you find the same twin rate and
165 states have signed and ratified
once you sign that just means you have
the intention to sort of agree with it
but if you ratify a covenant or tree it
actually enters into your local domestic
law so you're bound to implement it
which means that citizens can call their
governments accountable make that
government accountable for implementing
the treaty in their own country so it's
Universal 165 countries I won't tell you
which countries are signs I haven't it
goes beyond the moral Appeals of
bioethics moving right into the human
rights fear also internationally the
fourth and being human right it blocks
two groups as well as individual so you
don't get that not only individual
autonomy individual protection group
right group protection group promotion
in a sort of risk of reciprocal approach
and then poses positive feelings on
government and private actors and
actually were a center here were looking
at what the countries have done who
signed and ratified in their reporting
to the United Nations on their
obligations under binding treaty so they
ascended reports so we're looking in
right now for the last 50 years or so of
reports to see what they've done about
this actionable right to science and its
benefits in the meantime
2009 UNESCO started looking at this and
took a kind of a broader view under the
Ministry of the right to science
obviously access without screw nation no
benefits if you can't access it
opportunities to contribute freedom this
is a popular interpretation of sort of
put together this right to benefit from
science with expression yet another
right which is the right to freedom of
expression scientific expression and so
on participation in decision-making and
conservation development into fusion so
broadening out if you like and again
ticularly I'll spend a lot of time on
just the right artists to benefit from
science and it's applications this
however was taken up by the triple a yes
in 2010 and more from what is the role
of the scientific community to nurture
awareness of the broad social context
and the human rights implications of
article 27 of them became article 15 and
the triple SS just finished a survey
across all its members all the
scientists are there from people's
living dinosaurs do today des in social
sciences you name it and the results
should be coming I would be very
interesting to see how their work unless
you know they're very active recently in
the other right the right to freedom of
expression of scientists and so on and
finally looking at the word property of
TVA file for gh in this in this area now
when the framework was written we were
quite aware that it we're not starting
scratch there are other human rights as
I just mentioned
to the three dimension that have been
developed that work towards respecting
article 50 the right to privacy being
one anti discrimination fair access and
obviously procedural fairness so well
there is background there are other
stones that are there already out
building the foundations for the
realization of the right to benefits and
science and it's and masses so when we
wrote these of the framework try to keep
it on data data intensive set we try to
keep it simple because we wanted it to
be used and understood and this is like
a handy small hand will get you like
very short for scientists the aims are
broad under each painting there are
scheduled mechanisms but the
difficulties with doing this with
writing such a document a framework
crosses all countries is what we try to
do is to keep it at a level where each
country can see themselves culturally or
value-wise religion science social
economic within the framework so the the
thing was to keep the lawyers who
including myself and so on from adding
too many words to that power brought up
and how to train us to keep it simple
and by the way it's been translated into
13 languages and again by volunteers and
validated on to cross cross translation
back out to English so here are the core
elements you can see that there little
bit different than your usual autonomy
privacy justice mantra that most people
working in the field of bioethics and
law are used to and they're more
specific to data intensive science and
we get through each one has about three
mechanisms for how to apply them and
then have them interpreted in your local
jurisdiction so what else has happening
as we move towards the data Commons or
the biomedical
CRMs would say health-related data think
that's though that's the key here
removing from the TV multiplying medical
to health-related health as defined by
the WHL as not simply being limited to
the absence of disease but actually on
looking at the well-being and welfare of
individuals and populations well earlier
I mentioned this new EU regulation the
general data general data protection
regulation trying to get a head start on
what it means and what it can mean the
first is probably this peacock paper
which is a pan-cancer analysis working
group paper that within the
International Cancer Genome consortium
try to cross the cancers of pan-cancer
in a scientific way to come up with
different conclusions on on trends and
future and so on in terms of cancer data
inside the collaboratory that I
mentioned earlier and together with the
EU open science cloud so this is a big
project that will be probably published
at this year in 2017 and major in a
series of papers what we're trying to do
is look at this EU regulation say what
does it mean for scientists it's heavy
going I have to tell you even as a
lawyer I context you know pretty dense
what does it mean to be identifiable we
all know that if you put together danger
from here with a sample from there with
other data from somewhere else and other
samples where that's potentially
everybody's identifiable okay so I
thought out of the way that means that
you can't do anything because there's a
remote as opposed to a reasonable
likelihood of identify ability so who
actually our controllers versus data
processors under this new regulation if
they have different rights they have
different responsibilities and it's
people change roles I mean are the
annotators curators and data processors
are the data protection Commission's and
agencies or vehicle folders
and what about the data subjects
you probably heard you could not only
say yes or no you can eject two
different uses it has to be race the
right to be forgotten there the right to
access to say Henry give me my raw data
I don't care if I understand it or not
is that going to be the new way of the
future so we have to get some clear
guidance on what the duties means under
this new regulation we also need to
simplify a lot of consents are so
specific that they have more constraints
than they have percent so considering
that while removing moving towards a
broader consent with better governments
because if you're going to make that
leap of faith Andrew the trusted you
know broad consent is now also under the
common law and the common rule we need
to know that the government is terribly
oversight the military but even for very
specific disease projects and a lot of
countries still are quite restricted by
where the data leaves our model if you
say breast cancer of techniques for
ovarian and cetera et cetera simplifying
on the International sharing by having
codes to identify what tender cannot be
done rather than complicated data access
and data material transfer agreements
that take more time in the funding of
the project on the students at the
particular disease so that's the consent
code developed under the Global Alliance
we also have something called beacons
you've probably heard of these you've
been around now for a year or two years
I would say just you know like a beam
sending out like a sort of like a
lighthouse anyone seen this allele so
it's a discovery tool it's not a
diagnosis tool it's simply saying anyone
have anything that looks like this up
there somewhere
and it's very simple and because it's
such high level before you go into more
clinical stuff where obviously we will
deepen sentence
on you can actually discover who has
what where and perhaps collaborate in
future projects and these beacons are
now around the world so that's that's
great a more recent project between the
global lines and the International rare
disease research consortium is this one
the privacy preserving record or linkage
at the beginning we talked about the
need to link and why it makes for better
outcomes fair diagnosis that are
programmatic decisions and so on and so
on
but you don't want to be with by anyone
in it to everything anywhere at anytime
you want to make sure that if your data
is transferred out for public health
purposes or for your own diagnosis or
for your own subpopulation or community
project that there are you're able to do
it in a trustworthy secure way in order
to get the metadata that's needed to
make those calculations and you don't
want to be counted twice this happens
and the very disease consortium is very
aware of this that you think you found
you know twelve families who have X they
are all excited and then when you get
samples in put the data together it will
stop them if you realize that in
traveling around the world looking for
self looking for diagnosis looking for
understanding often samples and data or
less than different places with
different experts and are counted so
this is the deduplication and the more
we do linkage the words is going to be
an issue not just for rare diseases so
we have all kinds of privacy protection
people are securing people that
understand all these things I can show
you cryptographic and other other tools
and this is moving forward and should be
a project hopefully done by the end of
this year and finally we know that right
now there's open access open open for
aggregated data and we know that actions
to such data is really important for
statistical purposes and we also know
that we have data access committees for
controlled-access particularly even in
the International Cancer Genome
consortium and so on on the committee
set then check that project can release
data in a secure way so let's go ahead
the controlled access and perhaps which
you need to keep it for sensitive data
for children for vulnerable populations
and so on back to their middle road
somewhere and what we would call
registered access almost like an ethics
committee where you have expedited
review where you can have an online
system with some authentication
applicants but not all these data access
agreements and your institution
agreements and data access committees
that have to leave that episode reported
Esper and that's one that's one can we
build a system that is for data
intensive less sensitive low-risk data
faster but trustworthy on access system
and recall that registered access for
now so not all of the tools that are
emerging and if anyone online has some
are on this webinar has ideas for tools
that they need or work that they want
done you just contact the Alliance
rebuilds working groups as requests come
in and as volunteers say that they can
work on but I think the most important
thing between the Commons the Alliance
the goal will be sharing and so on this
app you can see that they say you know
you stand on the shoulder of giants
what the Giants really are just people
individuals collaborating and sharing
and there are really no Giants per se in
this effort to ethically share you have
access to big data and there's the team
here at Dell not only the center for
genomics and policy with their PTT of
the population project in genomics which
is a tool building arm and CTP is a
research going on so I'll stop there I
think I'm exactly huh on time lots of
time for questions great that was
wonderful date thank you very much again
this is Mark music from Stanford and
I'll try
to moderate the question-and-answer
period today probably the easiest way to
manage questions given the large number
of people who have dialed in would be if
you have a question please type it into
the questions chat box um go to the
GoToWebinar site and we will make sure
that we get your questions answered it's
going to be hard otherwise to have a
hundred people ask questions at once
while we're waiting for people to type
in their questions let me ask a question
myself then I can take that prerogative
uh you spoke a lot today about the idea
of privacy and protection for data that
is a consequence of a sponsored or
carefully conducted research what one of
the areas in data science that is
beginning to get a lot of attention are
the ethics associated with the use of
data that are collected not as part of
specific experiments but that are
collected routinely and a lot of
conversation about the use of routinely
collected healthcare data for example in
the case of electronic health records
that could be used to guide
decision-making as part of a learning
health system whether patients who have
the routinely collected data
contributing to analyses that could
inform treatment for other patients or
whether it is ethical to be using
routinely collected data to guide
therapy of other patients when those
data have not been actually collected in
any kind of a controlled manner when
Patricia Petty have any thoughts on that
thanks for that question
arms at a meeting of the American
epidemiological mmmmmm Association last
year and somebody actually brought that
up and said that there was a duty I I
would probably get to subscribe to that
but a duty to share such data so that
you as a patient can benefit from the
routine collect the data and the
mistakes made or the right treatments
chosen or the right intervention that
was taken or drug prescribed from the
patients before you and your scenario
then contributes to the better to
understanding of the patients that
follow you in the world and the
collectivity of your status as a patient
I find that quite um compelling I'm not
sure how often that is done yet and
whether perhaps while we're thinking
about data sharing it is in the medical
clinical environment that we've done a
lot in the research ethics department
and data security do clouds regulations
have we looked at how to routinely use
it share it in a responsible government
way I'm not so sure I mean I would be
hopeful that it is been care from a
quality assurance point of view I'm not
so sure that I should mention that it's
not the sort of willy-nilly free ruling
thing right now this corollary question
that came in the chat box which is what
when is data gathering considered
quote/unquote for health versus as part
of a research study how do we make that
decision yeah well that's where the
health care learning system comes in I
think that effect tremendous
implications on I know about you know
the codes of ethics for doctors I know
about the research ethics for
researchers but if patients are going to
become part of this feedback loop so
that they can benefit from research
using their data and samples of
individually and collectively I think
that distinction which currently does
exist and it actually is everywhere
between the healthcare duties and
privacy security and medical records
versus research ethical duties and
keeping of records and certificates of
confidentiality and the like that schism
still exists but I actually see see that
is probably going to be not totally
disappearing but definitely lessening in
the next five years and maybe exective
from now it will be gone interesting
there's a question there's a question a
user has posted will you please provide
the contact
information for request for policy
development also who can participate in
the working groups I might suggest that
when you upload a revised version of
your slide deck to the website perhaps
you might go through that information as
additional slides that people might have
access to yeah we'll do that just go to
the Global Alliance for genomics and
health and you'll get an you can become
a member the only thing you have to
agree to is a framework
you don't even have to agree the shared
a sex appeal ever the global lives you
know it's a fundamental tenants as I
said people get together from different
countries and on the different working
groups there's tons of them so just have
a look at the site and I will put the
address on my next set spot here is
almost a cynical question in the
genomics era can individuals expect
privacy and if no how would each
individual be protected with respect to
insurance the privacy of their diagnosis
and so on oh I forget on I I wanted to
cut it on pasted on my office door was
about five years ago privacy is dead big
thing was it was Tom how you doing or
something I should have kept it um what
we do live in society so if you have a
sort of optimistic view of privacy
you're living in a cage somewhere you
know you're alone and a valley between
two mountains other than that room I
don't think privacy is totally deaf but
I think it's dead in the sense that the
more you participate in the social media
or the more that you want systemic
approaches to education to highway
safety
- Aaron rjq to help quality health there
is a give-and-take
and there is some you cannot expect to
have better treatments without better
knowledge which of course means giving
up some privacy no one however has to
participate in research I like with that
clear in a hospital setting Quality
Assurance is extremely important where
you get something else other than the
condition that you came in for the
additional leadership controlling our
the quality but also having access to
data for patient care I mean regarding
that expectation of privacy I'm reminded
of the controversy in 2014 when it was
exposed that Facebook was doctoring the
news feeds of people trying to determine
whether increasing or decreasing the
amount of happiness and the news feed
would affect their posts and I think it
was most remarkable is that most people
seemed not to care I think the
professional ethics community was
outraged that this was obviously an
intervention that was done without any
kind of informed consent and yet most
Facebook users didn't seem to care much
at all and seem to suggest that well we
know that Facebook is creepy and I think
it for me and certainly marked a change
in the way I think a lot of people are
perceived to view the protection of
their data yeah if you want your data I
mean Facebook is one thing you can be on
it or not that's a choice I'll just give
you a very mundane example I find myself
getting coupons in the mail for the
store where I go in sorry to go screech
and I get I get points on exactly the
products that I copy and so I know that
are you always such as there are
meetings because everything is is
transmitted electronically to follow
your parent you know what you do to sort
of figure you out commercial your for
marketing whatever most people actually
don't care and I'm wondering you
sometimes and you know mayor Koopa by
election and legal-sized community
sometimes we don't create problems that
almost people don't don't really see or
care or wake up there's a question which
I'm I'm not quite sure I can parse and
maybe that question might want to follow
up with with something more precise how
does data ownership or the ethics of the
benefits of ownership fit in here yeah
ownership / property as you know is a
really thorny issue on most individuals
legal scholars would say there is no per
se property right in
all data now that doesn't mean that
under any system whether they use a
personal right system or property system
I have no property you can have a very
simple property right which is to
control its use you might not like to
sell it or whatever but you would have a
right of control even under property
system under a personal right to system
which are a lot of civil law countries
again on the question of integrity
personal integrity allows you to control
the use of your data so I think
ownership only comes into question when
you have something that's data that's
transformed and becomes valuable in
other words has it has been transformed
into a product that then can be sold or
owned now there is some question in
Europe that databases in and of
themselves might have property interests
but I'm not going to get into into all
of that but I used to teach property
line I even bore everybody on this on
this webinar with that are there any
other questions from the audience
with none Lily thank you this is a very
difficult topic it's also a very
important topic and I'm really grateful
that you had an opportunity to share
your thoughts with us today
great thanks everyone hope it was
helpful bye bye bye bye